hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to prankmaster
or as i like to call it bullying
simulator i saw this when i was playing
the other mobile game and i promised
that i won't be constantly playing
mobile games
but i just had to see the audacity of
this game because the audacity of this
is incredible i don't know if they're
gonna paint this kid sleeping as like
some horrible monster child
but to be perfectly honest i don't know
if any justification is there
that could justify the amount of torment
that i saw this guy being subjected to
so tap to prank color his face
with toothpaste is there no sound here
[Music]
what
oh my god this slime is
so real that's clearly fake wait what
happened
wait he wiped it on his face therefore
it worked did it not did it not deal the
audacity of this
the audacity his face was colored it was
just white but also who wakes up like
that
that they just immediately wipe whatever
horrid
substance is in their hand right on
their face
what what is what is that what is
[Music]
is there no sound yeah there's just no
sound there's no
sound uh lixian
hey i know an easy way to do this a
super easy way to do it
what you have in premiere you have
multiple like audio tracks and you've
got the record button right there
you just record right to it you do the
first take you don't do any second takes
because why would you do that you're
perfect the first time you're perfect
the first time
you're perfect the first time you're
perfect the first time
so if you could just get that done quick
now that'd be great um tax
bring him down why
why am i bringing him
[Music]
soup down i know it's probably super
glue
[Music]
what he'll try again
also what kind of deity creatures doing
this to this poor guy
ow jesus christ that's a broken ankle
like immediately
who the frick i am in mobile game hell
see here he is look at this good kid
he's got a zunis honest mop
he is cleaning his room and i am going
to prank him
look he's so happy to be cleaning he's
so happy
all right cement
[Music]
it stopped him from doing the cleaning
is that what i wanted this is
this is like
[Music]
oh right because this is gonna ruin his
floor
because that's what i wanna do i wanna
make sure that it's actually ruined
alexia make sure you did you get the
blue wings did you get that
did you get the eyes bulging sound
effects
did you do it good good
fart fart spray
who is fart spray
oh my god oh my god
uh andy threw up okay and i'm gonna kill
him
and i'm going to kill him all right i
did it
helicopter
oh my god are you gonna kill him
did i win kick the what are you doing to
the buddy
what are you doing to the well he did
call me a loser so i guess i have to
i guess i have jesus christ it's the
smack em up
it's the dude it's the digital buddy the
the flash animation
okay i'm doing the trick suddenly i am
i'm no longer what is it what did i
reward what i got
i got a statue of his head i cut his
head off and i put it on my
counter i cut his goddamn head off and i
put it on my wall
i mounted him like a trophy i didn't
mount him he's mounted on my
his head his mount i mounted his head
yes
tap to prank he's fixing his bike it's
not a prank it's deadly
it's deadly pogo yeah pogo
and he's broken both of his shins
well i mean honestly that's kind of cool
[Music]
i gave him a pogo stick rock and roll
springboard yeah give him extra bounce
get him some super hops
[Music]
that seems pretty cool
i mean honestly this is kind of dope
it's kind of dope huh guess i'm going to
be a dad
hey i wanted to make that catch oh whoa
whoa doc only i can spank my kid
otherwise it's illegal oh two seconds
out and already a complainer here's your
bottle oh
didn't think it was gonna be that easy
did you rules are rules
you don't what the am i looking at
what the what the am i look
what the what the
what the i mean i know what's
happening but
this is a mobile app ad ad
this is a mobile ad what all right well
i guess i'm doing this now
i just wonder why is there no audio like
no audio at all
well i mean there is audio right there
is audio there is definitely audio
hey a rock
ow
okay yeah we're gonna suck him into a
portal apparently
what did you kick what happened
what happened
what happened okay all right grandma
am i pranking grandma am i pranking
grandma
am i pranking grandma here i mean
grandma does look pretty cool
a different strip bowling ball straight
to grandma's dome
grandma i'm sorry your brain your brain
pan's about to be a lot more crowded
good lord oh god
yeah blow on your shattered bones
grandma what
[Music]
i'm gonna nuke grandma
can i please nuke grandma already can i
please maybe i've tapped out on my limit
of
ads
[Music]
is that suggesting that grandma just got
hit in the balls did grandma get hit in
the
is that what happened there wow i'm
really happy about all of this
this might be the worst game i've ever
seen in my life and it's not like they
didn't do
animation
and he's dead he's dead
[Music]
honestly this game where i murder people
might actually be better oh it's made by
the same people
lion studios oh it's the same people oh
it's the same people
does it actually have audio in this one
idle transformation
what does that even mean
[Music]
look at that dude what is happening to
him
look at this dude look at the dude
oh no wow look at him
oh wow oh wow
i don't know what the hell is happening
there but that is very funny
all right but i'm gonna go try to murder
people
because i think that literally oh it's
not downloading
i think after this i have to take a
hiatus for mobile games the entire
experience of playing mobile games is
is like draining on the soul it really
does feel like you are
losing a lot to just
get the most basic of entertainment out
of it
level one killed by electric shock how
does scissor plus kettle
how in the world how
how did you do that how
why'd you stab the ghost how did you
scissor a hole into a metal
kettle hanging to death
find a clue to kill him this guy is
literally just having a great
time
what happened how did you do that no
no no no no no
no no no no
oh please no this guy's
killed my hook why dog
okay apparently not how about the puppy
itself shovel
this is awful this is so
horrible great i did it
i killed people final destination style
they are gone
oh good a spin why do i have a spin
why do i care about a spin why do i need
a lucky wheel why do i need
any of this okay
oh good another spin
no no why the ads
the ads it's all just a freaking self
pepperette and cycle
it's just you get a mobile game that
advertises more mobile games
and it's just like every mobile game is
just like spamming every other mobile
game with their mobile game ads
it's all just a big circle so that
everyone can get everyone to
like install their own mobile games and
then eventually they'll just like
if they get them for long enough then
they'll put up ads so that they can sell
more mobile games but they'll lose
audience to those mobile games because
people keep bouncing around for
different mobile games
and all of it is just a
self-refrigerating cycle of everything
coming around full circle before they
get into more mobile game ads
what did i get i got a kill me kill me
shot my head off chop it chop my head
off what did i get chop it off
death tycoon you know
death tycoon the tycoon of death
let death reign choked to death
axe no i want i wanted the scythe
the size is my okay whatever
hmm
i'm having a good time i'm having the
best time
i'm having a very good time i'm having a
very good time
actually it's kind of entertaining just
because it's super strange oh i know
what you're gonna do
oh my god i hate every part of it i hate
every part of every of this but also
if it can just get me closer to one
single animation of
something happening it's great
oh good what if i don't want it
i didn't oh my god
[Music]
it doesn't make any sense no no
no no no no
see the thing is like i didn't get it
right i didn't get that
i still ended up watching two ads it's
so absurd
it is so obscene it is
what people have somehow tolerated
in these garbage games
killed by inertia great
[Music]
killed by inertia
oh yeah killed by inertial right you got
that
i mean in a morbid like uh kill my boss
kind of way
it's got appeal if only i could actually
enjoy the game
you know if only the game was actually
something that i could experience
stung to death
[Laughter]
god that screamed okay you know what
i've tolerated
[Music]
it is this allowed is is
look i get this sex sells but
is this allowed is this super fun
there are some things that are
inappropriate for kids and boys girls
are showing lots of parts of her body
[Music]
all right you know what i've had enough
i can't tolerate anymore
if i do it anymore i'm gonna lose my
mind i think i'm good
on the whole mobile game thing for a
long time what's weird is you know
when i was growing up on newgrounds you
would have like
a surge of creativity making all these
great games
just for people who enjoy not inundated
with ads
maybe they tried to find some way for
them to support their development or
people watching but
god it really sucks for people these
days it really sucks if this is the only
outlet they have
and i know there are better options i
know that there are some games that are
actually good and do provide a good
experience or maybe you could pay a
couple bucks and you could actually get
something good out of it
but my god this is so sad
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching
um i think i'm good on the whole mobile
game kick if you want to see the other
videos that i've done on mobile games
just recently uh
i'll link them in the description but
now i'm going to go back to
other games and stuff like that so thank
you
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
you